[Music]
in millennial things new little things
what are they doing now it's our stop
wait they oh yeah you are young I mean I
guess we're we're on the fence I feel
like I but you're still a millennium I
think Millennials start at 87 88
millennial values I think you do a lot
of the stuff that we do is actually
millennial really yeah yeah work working
unconventional jobs like digital media
stuff like that
Generation X is above us seven DS I
think people that were like young in the
80s and then gen Z is below us or Gen Z
is Millennials younger than yeah okay
isn't that Isaac's age no I don't think
they've even named
the early 80s is like a blend if you're
born in the early 80s it's zero but we
found out that it was or 18 now cuz I
just write a book about I gen that's
what they call it i gen cuz they call it
the iPhone generation it's also Gen Z so
it's born so generation Z is born mid
90s to early 2000 so that's Isaac you
born mid 90s no no I just meant that
they what you're celebrating like people
that were born in the mid 90s are only
like already in their early 20s yeah
they're like 21 yeah let me be younger
give me that let me let me tell you but
if you're boiling the mid 90s that means
you missed out on the 90s and that's my
favorite decade what nothing was
happening in the 90s what are you
talking about everything this was the
Ben Runge 80s grunge yeah I like the
punk rock orange I like Kurt Cobain
clueless I love coolers my favorite era
was 99 through 2003 2003 early 2000s cat
me though
I love bubbles popping during that time
three was like a year for music for me
it's shaky mine's like TRL it was all
like eviden and NSYNC and Backstreet Boy
like all the bad era Britney Britney was
taken over the world when I left pop you
remember that yeah song for my shirt
yeah mm three or four mm mm that's 2004
okay for I know specifically cuz I was
in Virginia and then they're playing on
TV and I'm like this size are you in
there oh we're visiting a navy buddy
doing swimming in my wallet is well I
wasn't from around that area that's
where the naval bases there's your
family military no oh everybody there
was military submitted by do it for the
gram a hotel chain is offering Instagram
sitters that will post on Instagram for
you while you relax
what who posts that much on its way
that's a lot of people but it and how do
they take so they take pre-recorded yeah
[Applause]
what's happening with even more
millennial than me that I thought that
that title meant that you could come
stay at the hotel for free and people
will take pictures of you I thought it
was that I was thinking I thought it was
like you go to the resort and then
you're chillin and then you have like
people on you're taking photos I thought
it was like you give someone your phone
what is it TIFF so I'm gonna show you
guys a video a video nice nice I hope
it's got the music oh that's a nice
Instagram picture I want to stay there
I like the color
I think a picture for you I feel like
it's like PewDiePie it's house over
there answer the English question like
why are we speaking English because it's
social media oh that's so true so this
is the relaxed we post as a new service
offered by a Swiss hotel chain called
abit hotels and that's pretty much what
they're doing is like think you give
them your Instagram login and they are
they will continuously update your
account while you're taking your
vacation we're both right Wow take
pictures of you though but yet Sherman
specifically of you but I'll just know
that they following you around they'll
be kind of cool but they're uploading it
then they write the caption thing like
they partnered up with ten well-known
influencers so they will be the ones
logging in to guest Instagram accounts
and posting high-quality photos I like
to see them try to take my [ __ ] yeah
they also comment back to people so
they're like active on your account wow
they can do it on yours but I think your
fans are gonna be like you've been
hacked you there speaking proper English
and they're taking really good photos
what the [ __ ] are they I don't even know
it's like hello welcome to Joe's
Instagram thank you guys for watching
I'll be exploring this hotel for the
next 7 days and you can watch my live
stories and keep up yeah it's gonna be
horrible we're like what the [ __ ] was a
[ __ ] no and they're responding
to the comments like you're like this
the lot of hacks it like
actually we're not hacked I am Joseph
you can actually relax in a hotel like
that if you knew that there was somebody
with your Instagram password just
randomly taking photos that's all of me
this is for like actual social media
people because I think when you are on
social media and that's your job
you either go to a place do you take
even more photos and you type in post
even more all your going there to shut
your brain off and you're just not even
gonna be online right so it's it's like
one or the other and I don't think
someone like this would help anyone like
us they're saying that this is a more
four so now 40% of travelers are
choosing their destinations by how
Instagram I like the black mirror so
sure because so my friend he's like the
creative director for Palms in Vegas and
they have so you guys know the clothing
brand revolve yeah love evolve yeah
they're awesome so they have a revolve
in palms collab where they have a sweet
it's a revolve suite and it's all every
single room is Instagram ready so I
think the lighting is good for you to
take pictures and stuff so all these
museums like pop up things like Museum
of ice cream and then the happy you want
like those are all meant just for you to
Instagram it that's crazy
on all the networking vents that we go
to - yeah yeah ooh love good lighting
and just everywhere and they like
decorated in a certain way with the
flower walls and stuff like that I feel
like all of Australia is Instagram
bobble every restaurant everywhere we
went to I was like [ __ ] they did this
for Instagram I bet you look like that
like he was very Instagram ready yeah
they did it for Instagram I bet you the
camel was already light reflected off
the sand two's and I found a [ __ ]
sandwich ready I went through this
Halloween party oh you were there
remember that guy that was dressed as
the Instagram wall on Melrose
now it's about angel we the big pink
wall yeah this is the pink wall that it
just it's just random pink wallet on
Melrose Avenue that everyone takes
photos in front because it's like bright
pink and it's like it's like really
small hmm yeah he literally dressed up
as that do you guys think that like all
right grim question because like we're
all in this fear do you guys think that
as Instagram becomes a little more
mainstream it's gonna become less cool
and people are gonna start like deleting
it like you know how like a years ago on
Facebook how people like when Facebook
started getting more mainstream people
are like oh it's so wack I don't have
what anymore Instagram I'm almost
disappeared because everyone was going
to snap chat and then Instagram come up
with Instagram stories and then people
came back and they made it easier to use
and there was link Facebook oh oh that's
a good point too maybe they'll know and
what mistakes happen with Facebook and
they'll just keep pivoting to make sure
they keep us in but like I mean seeing
that commercial I can just like that's
like older people like saying like Oh
Instagram we know what you want and
that's been pretty mainstream same thing
with Twitter - I mean Twitter still a
thing I feel like so many brands are on
Instagram like I follow almost solely
brands and my friends do you follow any
of those compilation like I follow like
fight something there's just all
different I do makeup makeup comple I
think I just I just go to my explore tab
and like those are all the funny things
are I don't actually follow them I love
the hack in the DIY oh yeah Kratz
yeah I live on that page then and do you
ever read the comments no they're
[ __ ] cold they're always like this
doesn't - five minutes
Facebook's coming back in a different
way like with video and groups oh yeah
there's a lot of video on now you can
watch content and then like the groups
are almost like they're like Reddit
chats but it's like you you can separate
Facebook people yeah so there's real
people so there's less trolling if
you're in a private group or whatever
and then you they're they're real
accounts it's different yeah so there's
like car groups like martial art groups
all kind of like I heard about that
Facebook marketplace that's kind of like
quick Craigslist used to be but better
yeah I haven't tried it yet but everyone
keeps talking about it it's
funny look up mirrors mirrors selling
mirrors it's it's pretty funny hasn't
that been around for a long time
Oh cuz there to take a picture of it and
they're all I can end up in college I
think I saw the couch on there no really
new marketplaces new it's like within
maybe like you probably just posted
something on Facebook anybody what about
it it's gonna be crazy what's gonna
happen like in the future because
there's probably gonna be like social
media [ __ ] that's more that's like more
popular with the older group or like
with different age groups or more
specialized on it's kind of happening
now kinda like radio stations yeah like
kiss FM that's like mainly pop and then
have all the other niche radio stations
and all the diesels listen to nine
different place on the way also for the
past like a year or two the only good
apps have been like Twitter and
Instagram and so I mean you will don't
use Twitter at all they're just like oh
that's not my platform you know yeah but
those have been like the only good ones
and now like now I heard vine 2 is
coming out in January yeah what do I
call it
it's like Bing or something like their
[ __ ] yeah I don't know how well that's
gonna lympus well I don't know it might
be and then also I heard that a lot of
the kids are on tic-tock tic-tock as
when I was listen the worldís that's
like the new musically I guess they'd
musically die out yeah I tried music and
because we're it's not art it's not our
age group you ever even downloaded music
kids blew up though you ever stumbled on
some like 17 year old with one point
form that was all those playlist live
kids dude no dude and then they came
over to YouTube and that's like where
how Logan Paul got like 10 million
followers in the day or whatever like a
year pitched a space
[Music]